[موسيقى]
لطالما اردت الطيران عندما كنت صغيرا وكنت
ارسم عده طائرات
دائما مي هو مهندس وهوسه هو جعل الاشياء
تطير اكرت الدراجه الطائره التي لديها كل
خصائص المروحيات وتطير كواده لكنها بمرونه
اكبر وبشكل الدراجه كنت اشاهد حرب النجوم
عندما كنت صغيرا وذلك الهمني لتصميم مركبه
بامكانها
الطيران الفكره تطورت من حرب النجوم الى
الواقع في ديسمبر 2008 حيث اختبر مولوي
بنفسه الابتكار لاول نموذج لما تعرف
بالدراجه الطائره
كنت اعرف ان ما اقوم به خطير لان ذلك كان
اول تجربه طيران وهنالك الكثير من الاشياء
المجهوله لكنني قمت بذلك كنت سعيدا لتمكني
من التحليق بسلام صديقتي ممرضه وجلبت معها
بعض الادوات في حال وقوع اي
مكروه وبعد عده اختبارات قاموا بتغيير
اساسي في التصميم اربع مراوح بدلا من
اثنتين قررنا تغيير التصميم لانها طريقه
اقل كلفه واكثر سلامه للتحكم
بالمركبه ويبدا مولوي دائما باستخدام
نماذج مصغره ويضع كاميرا عليها لتحصل على
فكره عما ستكون عليه التجربه الحقيقيه
للتحليق بالدراجه الطائره ويدرك كذلك انه
يتنافس مع غيره في هذا المجال اذ تقوم فرق
في لوس انجلس وجمهوريه تشيك بتطوير دراجات
طائره لكنه يؤمن بان ابتكاره سيكون الاكثر
تعددا
للاستعمالات وسيتم اجراء المزيد من
الاختبارات في الاشهر القادمه وسيكون
مولوي من يؤدي هذه التجارب ويامل بان تكون
النماذج التاليه هي الاولى للمنتج الذي
سيتم
[موسيقى]
تسويقه